pues acaba de dar su opinión el
presidente del gobierno español pedro
sánchez a través de su cuenta de twitter
en la que dice los ciudadanos han
elegido una francia comprometida con una
unión europea libre fuerte y justa gana
la democracia gana europa así se
pronunciaba el presidente del gobierno
español pedro sánchez hace tan solo unos
minutos cuando se conocían ya los
resultados provisionales que como bien
han estado recordando durante todo este
especial de france 24 en el que manuel
macro no habría ganado las
presidenciales frente a la ultra del
ultraderechista marine lepén los
resultados de las votaciones en españa
aún no se conocen las votaciones
definitivas pero lo que sí sabemos es
que durante la primera vuelta la
abstención fue muy alta aquí entre los
franceses que votaron en españa' una
abstención que llegó al 70 por ciento
que rozó el 70 por ciento de los
inscritos para votar en todos los
centros habilitados en la península
ibérica y en los dos archipiélagos
es de los que sí votaron el 10 de abril
eso sí el 39 lo hicieron por el actual
presidente y reelecto al parecer
presidente emmanuel macrón y el segundo
más votado aquí en españa por los
franceses fue el izquierdista de la
unión que sacó a cerca más o menos
aproximadamente el 22% de los votos la
contrincante de manera macro en esta
segunda vuelta madryn lope en la
ultraderechista sólo consiguió un 7 por
ciento de los votos aquí en españa así
que claramente lo que podemos prever es
que los votos de los franceses
residentes en españa se habrán volcado
sobre todo con el actual presidente
emmanuel macrón unos resultados que
tranquilizan en su gran parte a los
políticos en el gobierno ahora mismo en
españa y que uno de los
europarlamentarios de box el partido de
ultraderecha española ha dicho que el
macro no es todo postura y conveniencia
y qué crece por este gran resultado para
la ultraderecha francesa sin parar y que
es la única opción frente al globalismo
eso es lo que opina uno de los
eurodiputados del partido box el partido
de ultraderecha aquí en españa con
respecto a las elecciones que
afectan de manera bastante importante a
españa uno de los socios comerciales más
fuertes que tienen francia recordemos
que españa es que francia perdón es el
primer cliente comercial de españa y que
francia es el tercer proveedor así que
como bien lo he dicho antes y como bien
lo recordaba también durante la primera
vuelta en el especial que también hacía
france24 los resultados de estas
elecciones y sobre todo el resultado
ahora con un macro que es pro europeísta
tranquilizara en muchos aspectos sobre
todo en el comercial a los políticos de
españa